okay, here is some nice logical, just sensible
news, which is the democratic presidential
candidate.
Andrew Yang has ruled out the possibility
of running third party or running independent
if he doesn't win the 2020 democratic nomination.
Now, why is this news?
It's news because if the goal is to defeat
Donald Trump, why would you do anything that
makes a Donald Trump victory?
More likely, which a third party run by a
former democratic, a presidential contender
would do, and this was literally his explanation
yesterday at the Washington post event.
He said, quote, I would never do anything
that would increase the chance of Donald Trump
becoming president again.
The goal is to beat that man, get him out
of the oval office.
Now again, you might still be saying, but
David, why is this news?
Why is this something that you're talking
about?
It's news because there is a contingent of
the electorate in the United States, including
on the left and it's a toxic contingent that
has a sort of burn it all down mentality.
If it's not my candidate, then I don't care
who wins, even if it's the worst person, and
I would even encourage, this is not me saying
it, it's them.
I would even encourage them to run third party.
I don't care if that takes just enough votes
from the eventual democratic nominee to allow
Donald Trump to slide into a second term,
and this is particularly relevant today because
it's the type of attitude that had people
on the left who didn't like Trump but also
didn't like Hillary staying home in 2016 because
so they said they're effectively the same
voting third party in 2016 and now Donald
Trump increasingly controls the judiciary
for decades with the Supreme court picks and
now more than 25% of high level judges have
been selected by Donald Trump.
It ruins, he has ruined endless important
alliances, geopolitical alliances.
He has embarrassed the world in a way that
will take a very long time to recover from.
And that is why, this is great to just hear
from Andrew Yang and maybe this is actually
a good time to talk a little more generally
about Andrew Yang.
Uh, most people in my audience know that I
was, uh, both one of the earliest people interviewing
Andrew Yang, I mean more well over a year
ago before he was getting very much attention.
I won't say I was the first person interviewing
him, but very early I got interested in talking
to Andrew Yang because we've been talking
about universal basic income for years at
this point on the show.
But also my audience knows that I've been
critical of Andrew Yang when he has an idea
that I think is not 100% there, for example.
I also don't think that he's going to win
the nomination, but I don't really get some
of the attacks against Andrew Yang that I've
been seeing.
The idea of Andrew Yang is some kind of libertarian
Trojan horse.
It's very boring to me.
He appeals to some people who are on the center,
right?
Tulsi Gabbert appeals to a bunch of people
that are on the right.
The right, it would be wrong to say Tulsi
is a white supremacist because David Duke
endorsed her in the same way.
Yang is not, you know, some stealth right-wing
libertarian because some libertarians like
him.
There is a fair criticism to make about Andrew
Yang that he sees politics sort of as like
a project management thing or, or like a consultancy
you bring in a business consultant than they
just figure out what tweaks to make.
Okay.
That's a fair criticism.
Uh, you can say that Andrew Yang, uh, has
not fleshed out in detail the numbers behind
some of his proposals.
I was talking to a couple of people the other
day who have gone through the proposals in
detail.
They say the idea may still be a good idea,
but the numbers Andrew Yang has on his website
attached to some of these proposals and maybe
we'll do this in detail, not, I'm kind of
riffing here.
I wasn't prepared to do this in detail.
Some of the numbers don't really add up, or
at least they're not complete enough.
He hasn't demonstrated that they work.
Those are all perfectly fair critiques.
I've been critical of the VAT tax proposal
of Andrew Yang, but Andrew Yang is clearly
not running to screw over Democrats.
He's clearly not running some kind of stealth
right-wing campaign and he's made it abundantly
clear that he's not going to do anything that
will help Donald Trump get reelected like
running third party.
Andrew Yang doesn't take cheap shots at other
candidates when he disagrees, he does it respectfully.
He's pushed some important issues into the
conversation about taxation or large Corp
taxation of large corporations.
UBI automation, even if you don't think those
are the most important issues overall, we're
better off with those issues as part of the
discussion.
So in the same way that I said last week when
I talked about let's not idolize politicians,
uh, when you look w when, if you look at countries
where leaders are idolized and almost deified,
those are not countries that I think we want
to be like.
Let's also not see everything in black and
white.
Every candidate is either great or terrible,
good or evil, an honest actor or someone exhibiting
or, or, or you know, involved in some kind
of subterfuge to completely trick the electorate
about what they really are.
Andrew Yang has some interesting ideas.
You can be critical of his general approach.
He's being upfront, he's being, as far as
I see, honest about his intentions and his
goals.
And I think it's a great thing that he said,
no, I'm not going to do anything that will
help Donald Trump win, uh, including, uh,
a third party run.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I'm glad to hear reasonable arguments, um,
against Andrew Yang being a good faith actor.
If you can put them together.